schlagabtausch im bundestag wie viel
geld soll für den klimaschutz ausgegeben
werden
aus hunderten werden tausende auf den
griechischen in wien landen immer mehr
flüchtlinge aus der türkei und homophobe
fußballfans in frankreich werden bei
schwulenfeindlichen parolen die
fußballspiele unterbrochen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch sport gibt's auch in
etwa 15 minuten mit norbert lehmann ein
schöner konter familie ist der
klimaschutz eine menschheits
herausforderung ein kraftakt der
dringend bewältigt werden muss wie es
die kanzlerin aus drückt oder wie
fdp-fraktionschefin weidl sagt
demontiert die bundesregierung im
klimaschutz waren die deutsche industrie
das klima war das thema bei der
generaldebatte zum haushalt im bundestag
heute was die koalition allerdings
konkret dafür tun will und was das
kosten wird das bleibt erstmal weiter
offen cornelia schiemenz das erste wort
heute im bundestag hat die afg als
größte oppositionspartei alice weidl
zeichnet das bild eines landes das am
abgrund steht
sie ruinieren unser land mit der aktion
idee gleichzeitig auf atomenergie und
kohleverstromung aufsteigen zu können
und zu einem fiktiven datum in nicht
allzu ferner zukunft typisch
planwirtschaft das land co2 neutral zu
machen
die klimapolitik als roter faden der
generaldebatte angela merkel spricht von
einer menschheits herausforderung wenn
wir den klimaschutz vorantreiben wird es
geld kosten dieses geld ist gut eigen
sind wenn wir ihn ignorieren wird es uns
nach meiner überzeugung mehr geld kosten
als wenn wir etwas tun das ist die
wahrheit nichts zu
ist nicht die alternative die
bewältigung von klimaschutz und
digitalisierung sei entscheidend um
deutschlands wohlstand zu sichern so die
kanzlerin
zustimmung vom koalitionspartner der
kohlekompromiss ist ein beispiel wie
klimaschutz digitalisierung und soziale
gerechtigkeit im veränderungsprozess
unserer zeit zusammen gedacht und
verwirklicht werden kann
grüne und linke fordern deutlich mehr
investitionen in den klimaschutz und den
abbau von subventionen
ich will sehen dass sie machen diese
haushalt das was sie hier vorgelegt
haben und was dann irgendwie noch
beraten werden soll
das ist eine doppelte nur nämlich kein
plan und kein geld das kann sich das
klima nicht leisten streichung der
energie steuerbefreiung für kerosin
würde 7 milliarden bringen
mehrwertsteuerbefreiung für
internationale flüge 4,7 milliarden
pauschale besteuerung privat genutzter
dienstwagen 3 am ende müssen wir dahin
kommen meine damen und herren dass die
bahn unschlagbar günstig werden muss die
fdp fordert deutschland müsse mehr auf
marktwirtschaft und erfindergeist setzen
und warnt vor einem klimaschutz mit
askese verbot und verzicht wir werden
auf dem weg möglicherweise auch moral
weltmeister werden aber niemand wird uns
auf der welt folgen
viel wurde heute über klimaschutz
geredet konkret soll es da nächste woche
werden wenn es um die finanzierung geht
die wichtigsten stimmen aus allen
fraktionen auch zu den anderen themen
finden sie bei uns online auf heute de
stichwort generaldebatte im bundestag
alle reden
chinas regierung hat den deutschen
botschafter in peking einbestellt aus
protest gegen treffen deutscher
politiker mit dem aktivisten josua von
ausrutschern der 22-jährige ist das
gesicht der proteste in der chinesischen
sonderverwaltungszone seit drei monaten
gehen zehntausende auf die straße gegen
die wachsende einflussnahme pekings
internationale unterstützung für die
bürgerrechtsbewegung forderte rom nun in
berlin dann hier putzen berichtet
seinem auftritt beginnt jeder tag der
aus einem chinesischen konflikt
endgültig auch ein deutsches problem
macht und die hauptstadt zum
austragungsort ist ein unbequemer gast
deutschland müsse sich entscheiden so
seine botschaft seinen einfluss auf
china nutzen oder klein beigeben
zugunsten eigener wirtschaftsinteressen
deutschland sollte sofort den export von
waffen an die polizei von hongkong
aussetzen
deutschland sollte auch die wirtschafts
verhandlungen mit china und hongkong
ruhen lassen bis das thema
menschenrechte auf die agenda gehoben
wird über den einsatz deutscher waffen
in hongkong lägen keine erkenntnisse vor
so das bundeswirtschaftsministerium
gegenüber den ttf wasserwerfer auch
wassertanks dafür habe deutschland nicht
exportiert nachdem gestern abgeordnete
fast aller fraktionen mittwoch sprachen
gab es auch heute kein treffen mit der
kanzlerin
sie äußerte sich ähnlich wie zuletzt in
china eine von bon erhoffte deutlichere
ansagerin präsident sie blieb aus dass
die einhaltung der menschenrechte für
uns unabdingbar ist es gilt insgesamt
und das gilt auch im blick auf risiko
hongkong wo wir das prinzip ein land
zwei systeme weiter für richtig halten
sehr zurückhaltend heute außenminister
mars sein treffen mit wang vorgestern
hatte china erzürnt in peking wurde im
nachgang der deutsche botschafter
einbestellt und in berlin gab der
chinesische botschafter sehr
ungewöhnlich eine pressekonferenz nicht
so die eskalation im gegenteil zum
angriff sei ein aufrührer
bedauerlicherweise haben mancher
deutscher politiker solch eine als
stifter der gewalttat empfangen weil ihn
nicht die grundkenntnisse über die wahre
situation im hongkong fehlen
da muss ich dann davon ausgehen dass sie
politische kapital daraus schlagen
wollen
vom rest in kürze ab das problem sein
problem bleibt genau wie spätestens
jetzt dass zwischen china und
deutschland
griechenland ruft um hilfe auf inseln
lesbos landen derzeit so viele
flüchtlinge wie seit jahren nicht mehr
vor allem aus der türkei im august kamen
rund 8100 migranten über die ägäis mehr
als doppelt so viele wie im
vorjahresmonat
offenbar funktioniert der von der eu mit
der türkei geschlossene flüchtlings pakt
nicht mehr so gut danach kann die eu
alle die illegal aus der türkei kommen
zurückschicken
dafür bekommt ankara geld und hat
zugesagt die grenzen zu kontrollieren
annette hilsenbeck
diesmal kam vor wenigen tagen mit seiner
familie auf lesbos an
im lager moria haben sie bisher zwei
decken gericht mehr nicht und hausen
außerhalb des eigentlichen camps in
einem zeltlager es ist beengt
wir leben hier mit vier familien in
diesem zelt insgesamt sind wir 16
personen
wir haben gefahren auf uns genommen
wussten dass wir ertrinken können das
haben wir getan damit unsere kinder eine
bessere zukunft haben
etwa 10.000 menschen hausen in moria
dreimal so viel wie ursprünglich geplant
war
täglich kommen neue ansuchen platz
zwischen denen die schon warten ob sie
asyl bekommen oder nicht monate oder gar
jahrelang dieses system kann so viele
menschen nicht aushalten generell muss
das also verfahren beschleunigt werden
damit er für mehr menschen schneller und
fairer abgeschlossen werden kann
viele kinder leben im lager die neue
griechische regierung hat letzte woche
deshalb vor allem familien aus festland
umgesiedelt rund 1400 menschen
sachbearbeiter will man ein stand das
asylverfahren verkürzen und sieht den
nachbarn türkei in der pflicht wir
fordern von der türkei dass sie
ernsthaft dafür sorgt dass schlepper
netzwerke zerschlagen werden und dass
sie nicht zu dass das erneut diese
etablierten flüchtlings routen entstehen
[Musik]
das ist einfacher ist aus der türkei zu
fliegen berichtet ahmed er war zuvor
sieben mal verhaftet jetzt beim achten
mal klappt es beim letzten mal haben die
türkischen polizisten zugeschaut die
haben uns einfach gehen lassen
die türkei ist nach wie vielen migranten
den weg übers meer nach lesbos schaffen
hängt also vielleicht von der türkischen
regierung ab rasen ist dann wohl jetzt
droht der türkische präsident auch noch
damit die grenzen zur eu für syrische
flüchtlinge zu öffnen warum tut er das
weil er und seine regierung unter großem
innenpolitischen druck stehen die
stimmung in der bevölkerung hat sich in
den vergangenen monaten komplett gedreht
eine mehrheit betrachtet die syrer im
eigenen land nun als konkurrenz um
arbeitsplätze und um wohnungen das hat
erste pogrome gegeben
es gab angriffe auf syrische geschäfte
und auch der flüchtlings druck auf
syrien richtung türkei hat sich in den
vergangenen wochen wieder erhöht durch
die kämpfe in der region idleb präsident
erdogan
man hat heute mit bundeskanzlerin merkel
telefoniert aber soll es auch um dieses
thema gegangen seien und die botschaft
aus ankara ist ganz klar wir können
nicht mehr flüchtlinge aufnehmen als die
3,6 millionen die bereits im land sind
wir brauchen mehr hilfe von europa sei
es geld oder auch dass man selbst mehr
flüchtlinge aufnimmt denn die türkei hat
mittlerweile ihre eigene
flüchtlingskrise dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus istanbuler basar israel
dort kämpft premier netanjahu um seine
wiederwahl nächste woche und spricht
davon
teile der besetzten palästinensergebiete
zu annektieren
ob wahlkampf manöver oder nicht
netanjahus ankündigung löst große
besorgnisse aus un und eu warnen vor
einer eskalation
konkret geht es um das jordantal es
verläuft entlang der grenze zu jordanien
die palästinenser beanspruchen das
gebiet als teil eines künftigen eigenen
staates nicola albrecht raketenalarm
mitten in der wahlkampfrede premier
netanjahu muss in den schutzbunker
gebracht werden weil militante
palästinenser aus gaza raketen abfeuern
ob es ihre antwort auf die aktionspläne
sein sollte blieb offen
doch so hatte sich mister security wie
netanya genannt wird seinen auftritt am
abend nicht vorgestellt denn eigentlich
wollte er sich nur den applaus für sein
jüngstes wahlversprechen abholen
ich kündige heute meine absicht an mit
der bildung der nächsten regierung
israelische souveränität auf das
jordantal und das nördliche tote mehr
anzuwenden
die unmissverständliche offerte wählt
mich und ich annektieren das jordantal
soll wähler noch
immerhin rund die hälfte aller israelis
nicht nur potenzielle wähler aus dem
rechten spektrum sprechen sich laut
umfragen für eine annexion aus der
premierminister versteht dass wenn er
die wahlen gewinnen will muss ihr die
themen setzen und dominieren und darin
ist er sehr erfahren 60.000
palästinenser leben im von israel
besetzten jordantal ebenso wie circa
5.000 israelis in illegalen siedlungen
für israels regierung zählt vor allem
die strategische bedeutung der region
sie gilt als sicherheitsgürtel das
annexion versprechen ist aber auch eine
klare absage an den friedensprozess die
palästinenser werden ist als kampfansage
die eu als völker rechtsbruch doch
netanya scheut diese provokationen nicht
denn ihm geht es schlicht um sein
politisches überleben und das ist laut
neuesten umfragen nicht sicher als
antwort auf den raketenbeschuss ließ
netanyahu oft angriff auf gaza fliegen
doch auch heute feuerten militante
palästinenser von dort wieder zurück
dadurch erhöhen sich die spannungen noch
einmal deutlich so kurz vor der wahl
teile der bahamas sind ein trümmerfeld
vor mehr als einer woche traf hurrikan
dorian auf die inselgruppe und wütete
drei tage lang mit verheerenden folgen
mehr als 90 prozent der häuser auf den
nördlichen inseln sind beschädigt oder
zerstört mindestens 50 menschen starben
viele werden noch vermisst auch weil die
helfer noch nicht alle gebiete erreicht
haben britta jäger ist vor ort im hafen
der hauptstadt das so fließen
freudentränen
janet sieht seine söhne und seine
schwester wieder sie alle waren aus dem
katastrophengebiet geflohen auf
unterschiedlichen boten gelandet wussten
nicht wie es den anderen gilt jetzt ist
die familie wieder komplett
ich fühle mich gut also nicht wirklich
richtig gut denn jetzt brauchen wir
einen platz an dem wir mit den kindern
leben können im norden der bahamas ist
die lage beinahe unverändert bevor die
verwüstung beseitigt werden kann müssen
erst die toten gefunden werden hunderte
menschen gelten noch als vermisst
es liegt immer noch ein starker
verwesungsgeruch in der luft und es wird
noch lange dauern bis die suchtrupps
alle leichen geborgen haben
die regierung will jetzt dafür sorgen
dass die bewohner möglichst schnell
wieder nach hause zurückkehren können
waren das aber wirklich passieren kann
das weiß niemand nach offiziellen
angaben fehlen allein auf great abaco
nahrungsmittel wasser und notunterkünfte
für sieben bis 10.000 menschen die
private hilfsorganisation world central
kitchen verteilt hier täglich
eingeflogene warme mahlzeiten und
sandwiches wenn du hier mit
alleingelassen wirst mit einem zuhause
das aussieht wie das hier dann kannst du
nur hoffen ein bisschen liebe und
aufmerksamkeit von deinen mitmenschen zu
bekommen
eine gruppe ehemaliger us soldaten
unterstützt die hilfsorganisationen mit
ihrer aufklärungsdrohne aus der luft
detaillierte bilder identifizieren
unzugängliche gebiete oder menschen die
hilfe brauchen
sie kritisieren das krisenmanagement der
behörden es hätte viel schneller und
besser geholfen werden können
wir tun immer so als würden wir über die
hurrikansaison oder die auswirkungen
nicht bescheid wissen durch die
bürokratie gibt es zu viele hürden
zwischen denen die hilfe brauchen und
denen die sie bringen es wird ein langer
beschwerlicher weg bis die bahamas eine
der größten katastrophen in ihrer
geschichte überwunden haben eine
ausführliche reportage über die folgen
von hurrikan dorian können sie im
ausland zweimal sehen um 22 15
vor 18 jahren am 11 september 2001
steuerten islamisten flugzeuge in die
türme des world trade center in new york
und ins pentagon
um acht uhr 46 ortszeit dem zeitpunkt
des ersten anschlags gab es eine
schweigeminute am ground zero
angehörige lasen die namen der fast 3000
opfer vor
auch präsident amt und seine frau
gedachten der opfer still vor dem weißen
haus in barcelona sind zehntausende
menschen auf die straße gegangen sie
fordern mehr selbstbestimmung für
katalonien die fronten zwischen
unabhängigkeits befürwortern und gegnern
sind verhärtet
auch wenn sich einer aktuellen umfrage
zufolge immer weniger katalanen
vollständig von spanien lösen wollen
schwere unwetter sind über die
baleareninsel mallorca hinweggezogen
extremer starkregen ließ die bäche über
die ufer treten und hinterließ in
einigen ortschaften überschwemmungen
über cala d'or wie ein hagelschauer
nieder sehr ist in sich hatte an der
küste bildeten sich mehrere tornados
frühestens morgen soll sich das wetter
auf der insel wieder beruhigen
schwulenfeindliche gesänge oder banner
in fußballstadien darüber wird gerade in
frankreich heftig gestritten
dort ist es nämlich so wenn fans solche
grenzen überschreiten dann werden sie
dann werden auf anregung der fifa die
spiele unterbrochen
das aber geht manchem zu weit aus paris
tours walde
es war ein pfiff der im ganzen land nach
halte in der 27 minute unterbrach der
schiedsrichter die partie gegen
marseille nach dem nizza fans homophobie
lieder sangen und banderolen entrollten
auf denen von [ __ ] die rede war
ihre homophobie hat keinen platz im
fußball stadion siebenmal unterbrachen
schiedsrichter partien wie von der fifa
angeregt dem verbandschef geht das zu
weit
ich bin gegen homophobie aber ich will
nicht als geisel genommen werden
ich habe angewiesen dass spiele nur noch
unterbrochen werden wenn es auf den
tribünen eine gefahr gibt
damit rief der fußball präsident einen
anderen präsidenten auf den plan
der fußball soll menschen einen nicht
spalten und dazu muss er die werte der
eintracht in unserem land befördern
man muss klarheit in seinen prinzipien
haben und die richtige urteilskraft bei
ihrer anwendung
manche fans verstehen die aufregung
nicht
seit jahren singen wie sowas und jetzt
soll es verboten sein das ist unsinn
für den nachmittag hatte die
französische liga chefin fans und
homosexuellen verbände zum
krisengespräch nach paris eingeladen
wir reden von einem problem das kein
rein französisches ist homophobie gibt
es auch in anderen ländern vielleicht
können wir davon lernen wie man dort im
fussball damit umgeht deutsche fan
beauftragte sagen hierzulande würden
viele fans homophobie nicht einfach
hinnehmen in deutschland haben wir gott
sei dank die situationen auf einen fan
initiativen hier aktiv sondern haben
eine ganz andere akzeptanz in den kurven
die französische liga räumte am abend
ein mann habe zu lange hingenommen was
nicht hinnehmbar sei man wolle nun
vereine und fans sensibilisieren was
anderes thema gab es heute eine
handfeste überraschung das bittere aus
für die us basketballer im viertelfinale
der zuvor ungeschlagenen
titelverteidiger und top favorit verlor
gegen frankreich
seit 2006 hatten die usa kein wm spiel
mehr verloren im letzten viertel sid der
fünfmalige weltmeister in weiß bei einer
sieben punkte führung noch so ähnlich
wie ein sieger aus doch dann passieren
denn ohne einige nba stars angetretenen
amerikanern zu viele fehler freiwürfe
gehen daneben und frankreich macht im
südchinesischen dongguan das unmöglich
scheinende möglich besiegt die usa mit
89 zu 79 und trifft jetzt im halbfinale
auf argentinien die usa spielen nur noch
um die plätze fünf bis acht und haben
die chance verpasst als erste drei mal
nacheinander den wm titel zu holen
speerwurf-weltmeister johannes vetter
krönte beim leichtathletik
vergleichskampf mit den usa den sieg von
team europa im weißrussischen minsk
siegte vetter mit persönlicher saison
bestleistung von 90,0 drei metern
übrigens sein bester wurf seit 15
monaten und das vor der in zwei wochen
beginnenden leichtathletik-wm in dual
die länderspielpause ist vorbei am
wochenende wieder fußball bundesliga mit
top-spielen tabellenführer leipzig
empfängt die bayern auch ein duell der
beiden zurzeit besten torschützen timo
werner und robert lewandowski
anders als im nationalteam treffen sie
in der liga lewandowski sechs mal schon
werner fünfmal und beide haben sich bis
20 23 jahren ihre vereine gebunden mit
dem polen sieht sich timo werner noch
nicht auf augenhöhe der trainer will ihn
noch besser machen
insgesamt immer noch phasen im spiel
wird zu wenig zu wenig aktion hat die
die hat sind immer gut deswegen wünschen
sich als trainer so dass er noch mehr
hat von diesen aktionen nagelsmann sorgt
für ein lockeres doch strikt
leistungsorientiertes klima in der
mannschaft ein grund für den super
saisonstart ein weiterer das große
kontinuität da ist dass spieler nicht
nur hergekommen sind um einen durchlauf
station zu haben so was ja auch hier
etwas mit aufbauen wollen dass man hat
in bayern mit hoffenheim schon mehrfach
ein bein gestellt ein sieg am samstag
und leipzig wäre schon fünf punkte
voraus
das samstagabendspiel leipzig gegen
bayern zu sehen bei uns in der aktuellen
sportstudio aber jetzt erst mal die
zahlen von mittwochslotto die
gewinnzahlen lauten 38 17 28 38 42 und
die superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter bringt viele wolken im norden
und viel sonne im süden und der
september zeigt sich immer mehr von
seiner sonnigen und warmen seite
verspricht gleich katja horneffer das
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
christian sie was machen sie sich noch
einen schönen abend und bleiben wir uns
gewogen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren über
mallorca gab es heute heftige unwetter
die hängen zusammen diesem tief hier
über dem westlichen mittelmeer aber auch
am zentralen mittelmeer gab es heute
unwetter und das ist jetzt im september
so oft kräftige gewitter tiefs über dem
mittelmeer gibt liegt einfach daran dass
das wasser des mittelmeeres sehr warm
ist wir haben da derzeit
wassertemperaturen zwischen 24 und 28
grad
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen bei
uns in deutschland auf 15 bis 8 grad und
damit wird die kommende nacht deutlich
milder als die vergangenen waren
denn es liegen viele wolken über uns und
hin und wieder kann es auch noch regnen
zwischen der ostsee christ und dem
sauerland bei einem böigen wind aus
westlichen richtungen
der tag morgen beginnt erstmal recht
trüb dann aber setzt sich die sonne
durch es müssen allerdings auch einige
regentropfen erwartet werden und zwar
hier zwischen dem sauerland und dem harz
freudig wird am oberrhein mit
strahlenden sonnenschein klettern dort
die temperaturen bis 26 grad sonst
werden morgen 19 bis 24 grad erreicht
am freitag ändert sich erst mal wenig
aber am wochenende geht es dann für uns
alle schönen schweizer marita bei 17 bis
27 grad
schönen abend noch